[Musica]
[Applauso]
io in realtà vengo dal passato sono un
uomo della preistoria
sono nato nel 1959 c'erano i beatles le
minigonne martin luther king era il
momento in cui tutti noi sognavamo di
andare sulla luna era una notte
dell'anno raggio è questo qui ha
rappresentato qualcosa di veramente
speciale nella mia vita
questo è il com'era adesso è diverso è
il centro di controllo che la nasa di
houston che ha diretto l'allunaggio è
questo qui è stato un po il mito di una
generazione della mia generazione dei
sogni l'abbiamo visto tutti quelli che
c'erano l'avete visto dopo quali sono
venuti dopo i tuoi filmati come si
diceva qui huston vi sentite
ecco questo è quel posto la e io quando
ci sono entrato sul serio
mentre uno un po da piangere perché era
il sogno di una vita che ero riuscito a
realizzare venendo dal passato di andare
al futuro il sogno dello spazio
questo qui è un oggettino della olivetti
questo è il primo personal computer al
mondo italiano
questo personal computer da olivetti
veniva usato dalla nasa per calcolare
dove era la terra perché il modulo di
allunaggio aveva l'antenna la tena si
perdeva sempre la terra e con questo col
piccolo calcolatore ne hanno venduti 240
alla nasa
gli scienziati della nasa riuscivano a
calcolare più o meno dove era la terra
allora voi siete abituati ai ai giga
questo a fare quei 250 giga sapete
quanto pare alla memoria di questo
calcolatore 240 byte
questo è stato il mio passato e quindi
anch'io ho messo la tuta spazio a questa
foto non è però che è vera è quello che
ha co e lo sfondo ma questo è fatta
veramente a huston sua foto è un po più
grassottello aveva la barba giovane
ingegnere italiano e sono stato preso
l'agenzia spaziale europea e mandato
alla nasa
questo è stato l'inizio della mia
avventura in realtà poi io nello spazio
sono state la foto non ci sono mai
andato però dentro mi è sempre sono
sempre stato animato dallo spirito la
scoperta del nuovo del difficile di
comprendere poi adesso sarà anche è
arrivato la netta che posso dire una
cosa nuova foto lo confesso lo voglio
sapere
ecco questo è il mio viaggio nello
spazio che spero sia anche il vostro un
viaggio alla scoperta alla scoperta di
nuovo ma di nuovo per essere migliori e
dalla nasa da huston
atterriamo a casalecchio
voi direte molto in centro a casalecchio
con il comue stone ebbe a casalecchio
vicino bologna c'è un centro di
supercalcolo che è uno dei più belli
d'europa
questo centro di supercalcolo date il
capello onorate il capello
allora questo è un supercalcolatore
questo sono io dentro il calcolatore
marconi ovviamente a bologna se devi
chiamare marconi e c'è un tale rumore e
ci sono talmente tante ventole che
quindi fa questo effetto qui quindi
rispetto alla foto la nasa ho perso i
capelli e quei pochi meno rimasti su
tutti i dritti
è questo è un super ca che vuoi dire ma
che cos'è un supercalcolatore ecco
vedete questa lucina che si stanno
accendendo potete considerare soltanto
telefonini come questi
allora il calcolatore che avete visto
quello di più veloce che c'era il tempo
dell'allunaggio è più o meno un milione
di volte anche un po di più o meno
potente di un vostro oggi oggettino come
questo un oggettino come questo al tempo
dell'allunaggio avrebbe preso due
palazzi oggi un supercalcolatore moderno
e milioni e milioni di questi oggetti
qualche anno dentro il cuore che si
chiama microprocessore vedete questi
luci sono tutti i processori che
lavorano in parallelo quindi è un po un
gioco di squadra ogni processore fa un
piccolo compito calcola e poi ne arriva
un altro e arriva un altro ancora e
tutti insieme cerca di risolvere i
problemi molto complessi li vedremo
quali problemi cercano risolve però c'è
questo problema se ve lo ricordate
questo è ma di lon nel film il marziano
che ha visto l'avete visto tutti
immagino al film è questo qui è il nerd
della puntata nata e questo è il
calcolatore della nasa e lui se
ricordate nel film connette il suo
calcolatore il suo laptop al
supercomputer la nasa per cercare di
salvare ma dillon che è bloccato su
marte
allora questo supercalcolatore sta a è
un centro della casa che si chiama hames
dove c'è decente ristorante italiano
vicino quindi si mangia anche
discretamente quindi a parte diciamo gli
aspetti gastronomici è il posto dove c'è
il super qualcosa della nasa quello di
bologna sarà 200 volte più potente il
calcolatore che alla fine dell'anno
prossimo verrà installato a bologna avrà
la possibilità di fare circa oltre anzi
200 beta flop di spesso non stipetto
flotta
eyepet a flop italy si misurano le
macchine vanno a chilometri all'ora i
calcolatori vanno a milioni di
operazioni al secondo
quindi il peta significa è prefisso
che significa sostanzialmente mille
miliardi di operazioni al secondo
e si arriva si arriverà presto a un
miliardo di miliardi di operazioni al
secondo
questo è il supercalcolatore che verrà
installato in emilia romagna che sarà a
fine anno del prossimo anno
il calcolo più veloce al mondo di nuovo
l'italia l'europa
queste cose le può fare anzi le deve
fare poi di rete perché che c'è a noi in
fondo ma che ci importa di questi
calcoli che ci abbiamo i nostri
telefonini vanno così bene fanno belle
foto
questo progetto si chiama antares il
progetto antares che sembra invasiva di
un film di questi qui di fantascienza
dove c'è lo scienziato pazzo che cerca
uccide tutto il mondo realtà un
bellissimo progetto di nuovo fatto a
bologna con tanti partner europei che
cerca di sintetizzare nuove molecole
nuove medicine usando non le cavie che
non è mai una bella cosa ma il calcolo
le simulazioni eri e questo questo con
l'uso di intelligenza artificiale
supercalcolatori si riescono a fare
miliardi di combinazioni molecolari per
cercare di comprendere come arrivare
rapidamente alla migliore medicina
possibile
quello che vedete qua e la diffusione
nel mondo del virus dica quello che è
stato possibile utilizzando l'attuale
supercalcolatore del bologna e il lavoro
fatto con altri partner europei e di
sintetizzare rapidamente una molecola
che potesse curare
questa questo tipo di malattia con un
calcolatore normale ci sarebbero quelli
di 300 anni più o meno potevamo
aspettare perché no con il calcolatore
attuale con un mese di lavoro più o meno
ce la si fa con quello nuovo il nuovo
calcolatore si arriverà rapidamente in
una settimana con i calcoli di nuova
generazione sostanzialmente in un'ora si
può sintetizzare una nuova medicina e
parlando di medicine
c'è un altro grandissimo progetto
europeo del quale voglio parlarvi che
riguarda voi me il cervello umano e vuol
dire è che c'è da scoprire il cervello
umano e ben o il cervello umano è un
mondo inesplorato
sapete ci sono sostanzialmente
connessioni nervose 3 milioni di
chilometri all'interno del cervello
umano 10 volte la distanza fra la terra
e la luna
se uno prende se tutto è tutta la roba
che non c'è dentro e la facesse a forma
di filo andremo dieci volte avanti e
indietro dalla terra alla luna 3 milioni
di chilometri questo progetto di un
miliardo di euro
cerca di mettere insieme tutte le
conoscenze che ci sono sul cervello
umano è un po che per chi se lo ricorda
un altro film della preistoria il
viaggio allucinante era quell'astronave
miniaturizzata che entrava il corpo
umano quello che si sta cercando di fare
e di comprendere come funziona il
cervello umano
quante cellule ci sono dentro che cosa
fanno
perché se riusciamo a comprendere questo
arriveremo anche a scoprire la genesi di
alcune malattie che oggi non sono
curabili
le malattie degenerative del cervello
umano arriveremo a capire anche come
migliorare anche le macchine perché in
fondo l'intelligenza
più bella che c'è non è quella
artificiale è la nostra quindi questa
sfida del cervello umano è una sfida che
dobbiamo e possiamo vincere di
comprenderlo a conoscerlo per arrivare
qui l'idea di avere un po una copia di
noi stessi e dice ma che serve a proprio
noi stessi beh per esempio se andare dal
dottore invece il dottore dire la prova
sta medicina poi chiama mese non
funziona la prova su sul gemello
digitale io preferisco la prova sul
gemello digitale non so voi io sì e
stiamo creando il gemello digitale della
terra cioè stiamo creare immaginati
della terra come un'astronave e stiamo
cercando di mettere il centro contro
l'hotel a disposizione di tutti per
comprendere che ci sta succedendo
dove stiamo andando qual è il
cambiamento climatico che avverrà fra
una settimana un mese un anno
ecco questo è quello che si può fare con
i calcolatori
questi sono i calcolatori come le
conosciamo
sta arrivando una rivoluzione epocale
incredibile che ci viene la fisica
quantistica e google recentemente
annunciato ho raggiunto la supremazia
quantistica giuliano dell'età non è vero
è ma ma che cos'è sostanzialmente
costruire il sogno di l'uomo costruire
dalla macchina più sofisticata che c'è
per fare calcoli risolvere i problemi
con una capacità di calcolo infinito e
ma come si fa a questo con i gatti
questo affare qui e non è il beat e il
qubit e il beat quantistico devo dire
che è un gatto
quindi adesso insieme costruiremo un
calcolatore quantistico chi ha sentito
parlare del gatto di schrodinger allora
la storia è questa
prendiamo questo bel gattino e lo
mettiamo in un ambiente chiuso gattino
virtuale poverino perché per il resto la
storia adesso
dentro questo ambiente chiuso
c'è una macchinetta
che potrebbe uccidere il gatto la
probabilità che lo fa e come quando ti
lancia una barriera 50 50 questo
ambiente chiuso viene chiuso
fermi tutti adesso chi pensa che il
gatto sia vivo
alzate la mano ma pochi non vedo non
vedo ottimisti chi pensa che a gatto sia
morto vedere pure qua è siamo un po
divisi e questa è la fisica quantistica
in realtà oggi qua stiamo dicendo che il
caos del gatto mi sa che vivo e morto
potrebbe essere il remoto chi lo sa chi
lo sa
e quando lo gettiamo una moneta per
ariano che comincia a ruotare che è
testa o croce oppure la pallina della
roulette finché non si posa non lo
sappiamo no che cos'è
ecco quindi il gatto visto dall
osservatore esterno con la scatola
chiusa a tutti e due gli stati quello
vivo è quello morto che si sovrappongono
quindi tornando ai bit
vi ricordate no dei 301 non n0n 1 poi su
uno può essere l'altro è ma se io ne
metto due di gatti quanti stati ciò beh
se li metto due show due gatti vivi i
due gatti morti di un gatto vivo un
gatto morto cene o quattro di stati e se
continuo e se continuo crescono
esponenzialmente se in quell'ambiente li
mette si 300 gatti la probabilità di
trovare nei vari stati tutti sti gatti e
due alla 300 che sono più delle degli
atomi delle molecole esistenti
nell'universo io quindi con 300 gatti o
praticamente la conoscenza dell'universo
quindi un calcolatore che abbiamo
costruito con due gatti tre gatti
eccetera
arriva alla conoscenza dell'universo se
avesse 300
questo è un calcolatore quantistico è
una macchina che potrebbe risolvere
qualunque problema incluso craccare in
un secondo il vostro conto in banca se
la cosa vi preoccupa
fate bene perché effettivamente non c'è
codice di criptaggio attuale che resiste
a un calcolatore quantistico sofisticata
senza spaventarli ci sono altre cose
bene io vi ho detto che io vengo dal
passato
questo per esempio è quello che noi
chiamiamo la time machine è un sistema
tridimensionale usando supercalcolatori
che permette di conoscere e ricostruire
il passato
quindi voi entrate qui per esempio si
entra da notre dame
purtroppo adesso devastata e si vede
come erano tre danno 400 anni fa e poi
si fa per le vie di parigi
quindi ecco questa idea no che non c'è
più futuro non c'è presente non c'è
passato che è tipica della terra della
fisica quantistica quindi vivremmo in un
mondo sapete le balene vivono centinaia
di anni e ci stiamo chiedendo ma perché
non è possibile per gli uomini con un
calcolatore quantistico forse arriveremo
a comprendere meglio quale il cuore del
problema dell'invecchiamento cellulare
umano e quindi anche a risolverlo quindi
se la cosa vi interessa come prospettiva
non lo so ma insomma c'è anche questa
ecco quindi quello che cerco di dirvi e
il mondo del futuro è un mondo migliore
è sempre stata un poco si no è un mondo
in cui si potrebbe curare meglio le
persone strade più sicure e meno
inquinate
però c'è questo numero qua che mi
preoccupa in europa c'è in questo
momento un milione di posti di lavoro
liberi nell'informatica cioè le aziende
non trovano giovani che hanno conoscono
dai big da all'intelligenza artificiale
dite voi
nell'ambito del digitale quindi noi
siamo un'italia con tanti giovani senza
lavoro ma c'è tanto lavoro senza giovani
per questo io credo che dobbiamo un po
tutti prima di tutto fare questa
riflessione
noi siamo bravi c'è talento c'è voglia
di fare e c'è un modo un futuro migliore
che ci aspetta è quindi un pochino il
messaggio che io vi voglio lasciare e
che in quest'altro nauta è che un
mancato che sono io in realtà vorrei
essere con voi un pò in questa navicella
che è la terra essere tutti insieme
astronauti del digitale per un mondo
migliore
grazie
[Musica]